this is the loudest discord call i've
ever been
hell yeah brother good luck
kill me [ __ ] how did this happen
immediately this is the absolute worst
bro
come in here pretend to do damn it
wow that was quick trevor you're orange
right
yeah okay um so i was in admin i saw
uh mark stop in the hallway walked down
i just walked down and trevor you were
at the task and i didn't even see the
body i got the
thing to click report and you were
standing right wherever that was
was i yeah i think
for the record chris and i were in
electrical fixing lights
did anybody see anyone around storage or
was around trevor at all trevor you see
anybody around there
i don't remember dude what is this
bizarre defense that you have no i was
just doing my wires man try and enjoy my
day
oh wait wires that's the tell all right
i'm not skipping for
trevor we don't have enough info but now
this is the motive i don't want to do it
like i can't throw games
i know that when you're the imposter you
still have to play the video game
but it makes me feel sick
you know nobody really saw us go through
here so i probably could kill brian
um but i'm worried that somebody else
will come back out so
that should seem too risky i just get so
nervous you know i just get
so [ __ ] nervous voice is really deep
today
how has this happened i don't understand
at all just hang out
wait for the timer
okay um all right it is
lower left side reactor
and wait hold on there's two bodies
there are two blocks oh
[ __ ] okay i didn't know okay so i was uh
there's another body
which uh i literally saw after the
emergency was called
oh and uh ethan is not dead so then
anything oh it's in that body that you
were
walking right so i literally i went and
i did i went and i did the nav
with where you have to match up the
arrow thing and then
right as i exited from that it said
report and then the body
the other body was found this is real
life
gamers you can vote me out if you want
but i actually did not see the body
because it was hidden behind the chair
in nav that's convenient you know how
how did you know it was hidden behind
the chair i'm just assuming it was
not in the chair ethan
ethan you can vote me if you want vote
me if you want
everybody's targeting my birthday boy
because he's bad at speaking
all right so it's probably ethan yes
that's on ethan
i'm just gonna stand here and pretend to
do this though and not kill
ethan
because that task only takes like a
second right so we just [ __ ] do that
and then we peace out
or i could i could have killed chris
there
no there's too many of them over that
side of the map which does mean they're
all accounted for
oh we should sabotage more that's too i
can't click it now because it's too
obvious that i was just [ __ ] standing
there
okay do this one and then we'll do a
little
we go to just you know disrupt the pack
is really the plan
i would like to kill you okay
cool
[Laughter]
it was in a hallway on a hallway i was
on my way to the right side
and uh yeah this is the second body you
came across right
bloody mm-hmm yeah seems like sam is
trying to frame me
i don't know about that i passed alana
and uh yeah then it was on the left
i think yeah
this round i've not seen ethanol shovel
guys guys guys i don't know what to do i
don't know what to do i don't know what
to do
i voted brian just because what you said
but i i didn't feel good about it
okay okay okay great i feel like that's
probably good
that's probably good we probably did a
good thing i think that was good i think
we had to we should have we had to vote
there and that was the worst we had
okay so now i've really gotten away with
this i think that i should just go for
it actually
is the thing um and like not even
worried about being caught at this point
because we could get the win
if even if i get caught right
hey
okay easter let's put in some good work
for you but you're imposter again and
you have work to do buddy
i could just kill bloody right now you
know because people rarely go up the top
so if we just do that and then we just
[ __ ] bounce
med bass not a good place to be though
okay okay okay okay okay everything's
fine
this is awkward all right hello
trevor we're going to talk about this
talk about what the body that i just
found next to you while you were doing
tasks
cafeteria yeah top right so i walked
into cafeteria there was a body
and he was like right next to it not
doing anything about it and maybe not
maybe he just missed it i don't know but
i just saw it right next i did miss
it and it was top right or center it was
like top right like next to the leaf
uh where you throw the leaves out okay
so do we we have 25 seconds left
do we want to vote chris or trevor do we
want to skip
because you want to do a 50-50 yeah
shall we just babysit chris the next
round see where he goes what he does
guys i'm telling you i came down okay
what are we doing
math is on our side
okay well i could just kill eddie that
no good thing i [ __ ] didn't do that
holy [ __ ]
okay so i threw weapons i went down
into o2 to do some tasks and then
outside of shields there was a dead
trevor i was just with shelby and who
else was in the room with us shelby
i was walking out of electrical and you
two walked in it was okay
yeah okay brian and chris both near o2
like around in navigation i was
babysitting chris a little bit but not
too much
uh so any of them could have gone down
to shields
and then come back up amber where were
you telling me
well i had a task in navigation so i was
like waiting for chris to walk down
there
with 20 seconds left i would like to ask
the age-old question
mark what were you doing
[Laughter]
10 seconds buddy was yes
just finishing up doing a task
wow to go get a coffee
material and i'm on my way it again
oh my
okay if not your finest work probably
shouldn't have killed that particular
person is all i'm going to say
i could kill brian right now but i don't
feel like i want to do that either
we just you know pretend to look in the
cams and then we walk over and we
we commit crime like this is also a risk
but i'm just gonna do that
i need to get sighted i need somebody to
see me
could anybody please see me just
somebody see
me okay
i could do another one i could
but i i better do it i'm gonna do it
okay we're just
it's just a [ __ ] rampage out here
killmonger please ethan
please [ __ ]
[Music]
he was in the doorway to the reactor
okay okay chris died and brian
and that was three think three oh
that's okay because i know
possibly where chris died i had just
seen
chris quite recently uh
and the people who walked past me when i
was walking away from chris were
mark and ethan where sorry where was
chris
i don't know the rooms is the problem
the the one that's left
okay the farthest left room the one
sorry the farthest right room the
father's the one is the
furthest right the furthest right and
then i walked up sounds like nav
and then to towards cafeteria through
weapons
yes and i saw you passing through
weapons
but wait wait who are we actually
reporting here i believe
oh
someone of us is a murderer
oh my god
figure him out because he's just a
[ __ ] dumbass all the time
i love you so much
[Music]
alana you saw both shelby and alana saw
mark right
yes yeah do we want to vote vote mark
because there's only
look mark was there before you worry
then that's not
ever on the left side at all okay i'm
gonna vote mark because he's being
weird and i'm i cannot read him okay
okay
i am like jesus
what does that mean everyone said the
cross
the game going to end did we win yeah
[Music]
oh my god
yeah holy [ __ ] i killed a lot of people
i'm not
that ambitious crewmate on earth but i
will do nothing to defend myself that
was a really good game
i know let's go why couldn't i just get
a last game where i didn't have to do
this
you know how is trevor's imposter i
actually don't know
that's the thing oh
i just saw trevor i just saw i just saw
trevor kill
uh bloody that was are you kidding me
there's like four people there
can confirm just came off of a task
jesus christ
can confirm there were four people or
can confirm trevor
i'm confirmed uh there's a dead body
okay well it's just a group of people i
think it's trevor
uh i'm almost positive that it's trevor
because i think the other person that
was over there which i
think was eddie uh was doing the task
no i wasn't nav and brian was just saw
me was it amber you know who you [ __ ]
so
it was a green it was a green person
amber so it was you no i just literally
did wires
huh no no that's what i mean is you were
doing wires in storage right
yeah yeah okay you were doing wires in
storage
wait so you hit the task up and the
other person was trevor and i saw a body
fall and trevor was right next to it
and i saw
i feel like if ethan was the impostor he
wouldn't be throwing
accusations at two people when he thinks
it's not early but also i don't want to
throw if it is ethan so it is also the
last game though he could have got like
a chaotic
evil boy
either i i'm skipping this i'm not going
to ask i am not enough
hey guys if i'm dead it's
i don't trust anyone in that that trio
i didn't really have to do anything
there okay why don't we just go pretend
to do like the toss that's like right
here
you know should i do this i shouldn't
but no i could have now
shall be able to see me
we are going to do swipe task pretend to
do this and then we're going to kill
shelby
and then we're going to bed
where be the body all right i'm
reporting the body again i know that
makes me look
looks it's real sus but i'm not gonna
walk into admin find a body and then
walk out because that would be
not great that did get amber last time
yeah
uh so i saw i saw shelby in uh
admin okay only person i saw on admin
was chris when i was doing card swipe i
went down
into electrical where i have four
different tasks that's a lot of detail
um i was in med bay i saw amber there i
was just leaving
and to walk down and i walked into
storage so i guess i walked past admin
but i definitely didn't go in there
anyways you're doing lawyers in admin
or uh storage right yep yeah you saw me
come from below i don't want ethan
accusing me again
where were you at and also chris i was
in cafeteria i just finished a tuscan
cafeteria and then had to go to the
other side i was
about to head to midbay i was interested
in then too
and i did um the leaves and i could say
mark was with me
dawson leaves out into the sky chris is
the only person that i also saw in
cafeteria
so chris wasn't admitted did anyone walk
into admin like mid game at all
no that was late game when i i chris uh
left after me that's the only thing i
saw
after you okay i'm concerned that ethan
has been like last game baby chaos uh
and that's what's happening yeah maybe
i'm still voting trevor again because i
literally [ __ ] saw him
kill bloody oh my god oh my god so
that's what i'm doing because i don't
have anything else i'm just gonna do
this
because i think it's
[Laughter]
whatever i do here i think i should keep
ethan alive
is all i'm [ __ ] saying but what if i
just never [ __ ]
i just killed ethan i literally just
killed ethan
i shouldn't i didn't he was the one i
didn't want to kill why the [ __ ] did i
do that
okay well at least i have accountability
buddies uh but i didn't want to kill
ethan
just two speedy sometimes uh [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
i ruined all my own plans i'll kill you
[ __ ] jump in here i guess whatever
you know it's cool calms
oh my god
holy [ __ ] we did just get a triple and
you saw him kill someone and we did it
anyway